nos dicen y han anotó 144 puntos esta
temporada de fútbol anotó todos los
puntos con goles de campo de 50 yardas
esto es realmente impresionante 50 esto
está cerca incluso de romper el récord
de la liga nacional de fútbol americano
creo que el récord es de 60 yardas o
algo así
así que guían parece un individuo
bastante impresionante anotó todos sus
puntos con goles de campo de 50 yardas
subrayar en esta parte porque estoy
impresionado de la lejanía de esos goles
de campo y cada uno vale tres puntos
cada uno de los goles de campo en el
fútbol
y es importante aclarar que el fútbol
americano para los estudiantes de otros
países que puedan pensar que hablamos de
soccer cada gol de campo en el fútbol
americano vale tres puntos además
sabemos que jugó en 16 partidos esta
temporada cuántos goles de campo anotó y
han en cada juego supone que realizó la
misma cantidad para cada juego este
jugador es un pateador de goles de campo
increíblemente consistente anotó goles
de campo de 50 yardas y además anotó la
misma cantidad en cada juego entonces lo
que vamos a pensar es cuántos goles de
campo anotó en cada juego ahora hay un
par de formas de resolver este problema
primero podríamos encontrar cuántos
goles de campo anotó en la temporada
bueno anotó 144 puntos en total y si lo
dividimos entre 3 ya que sabemos que
cada gol de campo vale 3 puntos 3 puntos
por cada gol de campo entonces dividimos
el número total de puntos entre los
puntos por gol de campo y esto nos dará
el número total de goles de campo que
anotó y esto será igual am
bueno cuántas veces cabe 3 en 144
hagámoslo de este lado 3 no cabe en 1
entonces utilizamos el 14 3 cabe cuatro
veces en 14 4 por 3 es 12 y después
restamos 14 menos 12 es igual a 2
bajamos el 43 cabe 8 veces de manera
exacta en 24 8 por 33 24 y no tenemos
residuo entonces 144 entre 3 es 48 por
lo tanto en toda la temporada anotó 48
goles de campo ahora bien todavía no
respondemos la pregunta cuántos goles de
campo anotó y han en cada juego y
recuerda suponemos que en cada juego
anotó la misma cantidad así que este es
el número total de goles de campo que
anotó en 16 juegos para encontrar el
promedio que anotó en cada juego
tendremos que dividir eso entre 16
entonces dividamos 48 goles de campo en
total entre 16 juegos y eso será bueno
48 entre 16
esto nos da tres goles de campo por
juego vamos a notarlo muy bien y hemos
acabado cuantos goles de campo anotó y
han en cada juego y han anotó tres